GOT ONE OF THE TOP HEAD
COACHES OF ONE OF THE TOP
TEAMS IN ALL THE LAND. IT IS
MARCH. IT IS THE FIRST OF
MARCH SO IT IS TIME FOR
APPRECIATE THE HEAD COACH OF
BAYLOR BASKETBALL SCOTT TRUE
CALLING IN TO THE RICH EYES
AND SHOW HOW ARE YOU COACH
MAN? I'M DOING GREAT AND
YOU'RE RIGHT NFL NEWS IS
SUPER BUT IT'S MARCH MADNESS
TIME. SO IT'S BASKETBALL TIME.
EXCELLENT AND I
IT YOU NOT SITTING HERE
SAYING OH GOSH, I AGREE TO DO
THE RICH EISEN SHOW. AND THEN
WE AUTOMATICALLY LOSE OUR
FIRST GAME OF THE YEAR AND
YOU DON'T HOLD IT AGAINST ME.
SO I GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT
COACH SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE VERY
HANDY. THE OTHER THING IS I
KNOW YOU'RE AWFUL. I CAN SEE
THE SMILE ACTUALLY THREW THE
PHONE WITH MICHIGAN JUMP JUMP.
WE'VE BEEN OVER US TODAY
NUMBER TWO. UH, WELL AS YOU
KNOW, IT'S JUST IT'S JUST A
NUMBER RIGHT NOW AND IT'S HOW
YOU DO OVER THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS, RIGHT? I MEAN, HEY
SPOKEN LIKE A COAT SOUND
LIKE THAT. YEAH.
IT'S BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT? I
DON'T LIKE SPIKING ANYTHING
BASKETBALL FOOTBALL UNTIL
OBVIOUSLY THE THE WORK IS
DONE AND CERTAINLY IN THIS
YEAR. YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
SAYING? ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN
IN MEN. WHAT A JOURNEY YOU
GUYS HAVE ALREADY BEEN ON
THIS YEAR SEVEN POSTPONEMENTS
FOR CANCELLED GAMES. YOU'VE
GOT THREE IN THE NEXT SIX
DAYS TO MAKE UP FOR A LOT OF
THAT. I MEAN, HOW HAS THIS
YEAR BEEN FOR YOU TO COACH
COACH TRUE? WELL FIRST AND
FOREMOST, I THINK EVERY COACH
OUT THERE.
AS REALLY WORKED WELL
TOGETHER TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER GAMES THAT NORMALLY
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO HAPPEN
BECAUSE WE WANTED OUR GUYS TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY
AND ALL THEY WERE SACRIFICING
AND FOR THE GAME, THEY LOVE
TO REPRESENT THEIR SCHOOL'S
REALLY HATS OFF TO THE
COACHES OUT THERE THAT MADE
GAMES HAPPEN IN THE
NON-CONFERENCE AND THEN WHEN
THINGS OPENED UP IN
CONFERENCE AND THEY'RE ABLE
TO FULFILL GAMES AND THEN I
THINK EVERY COACH AT TELL YOU
BEEN AMAZED WITH JUST HOW
MUCH OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ABOUT
SACRIFICED AND THEIR
ATTITUDES AND WHAT THEY'VE
DONE THIS YEAR IN QUITE
FRANKLY. I MEAN WHEN GAMES
GET CANCELLED THEIR POSITIVE
AND UPBEAT NIGHT COACH.
NEXT? I MEAN, THEY'RE NOT
HOLDING THEIR NOT POUTING AND
IT'S A SITUATION WHERE
THEY'RE JUST THANKFUL TO BE
PLAYING GAMES. AND I KNOW
THAT'S THAT'S ALWAYS A JOY
WHEN YOU'RE AROUND GUYS.
ARE GOING TO BE FUTURE
LEADERS OF THIS COUNTRY AND
THEY CAN HANDLE ADVERSITY AND
SUCCESS AND THEN OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS STATEWIDE JUST
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO. HOW
ABOUT IT AFFECT WHAT WAS
GOING ON WITH YOU YOUR
PROGRAM WITH THE THE POWER
GOING OUT WATER. NOW BEING
WHAT WE WERE WE ARE BLESSED
BECAUSE YEAH, WE WERE BLESSED
BECAUSE OUR PLAYERS WERE ALL
GOOD. BUT THE STAFF ON THE
OTHER HAND WE HAD ABOUT HALF
OUR STAFF WITHOUT POWER AND
ELECTRICITY. SO
MY GOD
IT WAS IT WAS IT WAS IT WAS
FIREPLACES WERE THE WHERE THE
HEATING MECHANISM ONE OF OUR
IN THE IN THE FIREPLACE FOR
THE FAMILY, AND I KNOW I KNOW
YOU TALK ABOUT A ONCE AND A
HUNDRED-YEAR PANDEMIC YOU
THROW IN ONCE IN A HUNDRED
YEARS SNOWSTORM AND YOU KNOW
IN TEXAS WE GET ANY SNOW. WE
DON'T HAVE THE SNOW PLOW SNOW
SHOVELS ICE SCRAPERS. I MEAN
EVERYTHING SHUTS DOWN AND
WITH THE FRIGID
TO CHOOSE I MEAN WALGREENS A
GROCERY STORES WERE EMPTY YOU
HAD DRUG STORES WERE SHUT
DOWN HOSPITALS WEREN'T DOING
SURGERIES OR ANYTHING. I MEAN
IT WAS IT WAS EVERYTHING WAS
FOR FOUR OR FIVE DAYS ON
LOCKDOWN. BASICALLY SCOTT
DREW BAYLOR BASKETBALL HEAD
COACH HERE ON THE RICH EYES
AND SHOW AND OBVIOUSLY WITH
YOUR TEAM HAVING TO GET I
GUESS CONDITIONING BACK AND
GAME PREPAREDNESS BACK AFTER
A COVID BREAK LAST PLACE TO
TRY AND GET BACK TO SPEED
WOULD BE I GUESS.
THE FOG ALLEN FIELDHOUSE ON
SENIOR NIGHT WHERE THEY HAVE
NOT LOST I THINK IN 40 YEARS
OF SOMETHING LIKE THAT. SO
HOW DO YOU ASSESS YOUR TEAM
ENTERING MARCH RIGHT HERE
COACH. WELL THE GREAT THE
GREAT THING IS WHEN YOU GET
GOING TO BE IN THE NCAA T ARE
TOURNAMENT OR JUST LIKE THE
TEENS WERE FACING NOW. I MEAN
LIKE YOU SAID THAT KANSAS ON
SENIOR NIGHT THAT DONE GET
HARDER THAN THAT AND THEN
WE'RE AT WEST VIRGINIA.
THEY'RE RANKED SIXTH IN THE
AND THEN WE FINISH UP WITH
OKLAHOMA STATE AND TEXAS TECH
AND COACH BOYNTON COACH
BEARDED DONE OUTSTANDING JOBS
WITH THEIR GROUPS. AND SO
THAT'S SIX SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN IN THE NATION. IF
THAT DOESN'T GET YOU READY
FOR MARCH MADNESS, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT WILL WRITE THEM IN
THE PLANS FOR FOR
INDIANAPOLIS WHERE YOU'LL BE
ALL BUBBLED UP IF YOU GOTTEN
SOME SORT OF PROTOCOLS
ALREADY IN HAND BECAUSE YOU
KNOW, OBVIOUSLY YOUR PLACE
IS SECURED HOW LONG YOU STAY
THERE IS IS OBVIOUSLY GOING
TO BE ON YOU AND YOUR
COACHING STAFF, BUT
WHAT'S THAT PROCEDURE LIKE
RIGHT NOW FOR YOU COACH AS
YOU GO THROUGH EVERYTHING?
WELL, I DON'T KNOW ALL THE
DETAILS. BUT FROM WHAT I WHAT
I RECOLLECT AND WHAT I WHAT I
WHAT I KNOW IS OUR CONFERENCE
TOURNAMENT IS BASICALLY
TRYING TO DO THE EXACT SAME
THING TO KEEP US SAFE. NUMBER
ONE, AND THEN NUMBER TWO
PREPARE US FOR WHEN WE GO TO
INDIANAPOLIS. SO ONE THING I
CAN TELL YOU EVERY COACH
REALLY APPRECIATES HIS THEN
GATHERED IS IMAGES GROUP OF
WORKED REALLY HARD. HE DOES
A GREAT JOB OF PROVIDING
WITH A USUALLY THE ANDY KATZ
INTERVIEWS AND THEN IS VERY
ACCESSIBLE TO COACHES WITH
THE COMMITTEE'S ON TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT TAKES OUR
INPUT AND I THINK
EVERYBODY UP THERE LAST
MARCH NOT HAVING AN NCAA
TOURNAMENT IS GOING TO BE
REALLY REALLY EXCITED FOR
THIS ONE SCOTT DREW HERE ON
THE RICH EYES AND SHOW BOY
COACH. I MEAN YOU'VE COACHED
AND EVERYTHING, HUH HOW YOU
GOT, YOU KNOW INTO THE THE
GIG IN BAYLOR WITH THE SCANDAL
WITH COACH BLISS
BEFORE YOU
YOU AND HOW YOU WERE ABLE TO
MANAGE AND NAVIGATE THIS
PROGRAM OUT OF THAT AND INTO
SUCCESS DURING A PANDEMIC.
HOW OFTEN DO YOU HAVE YOU
LEANED ON YOUR DAD ON HOMER
TO GET AT? JUST HOW LONG DID
WELL, THE GOOD THING IS DURING
SEASON ESPECIALLY THERE'S
NOTHING BETTER THAN HAVING A
HALL OF FAME DAD WHO'S THERE
THERE TO GIVE YOU ADVICE AND
KNOW FIRST AND FOREMOST.
WHAT TO SAY HOW TO SAY IT
BECAUSE YOU'RE FEELING AND
THAT'S BEEN A TRUE BLESSING
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY MY BROTHER
BRYCE DOESN'T SAME FOR ME,
BUT I MEAN WE WE'VE GONE
THROUGH STUFF THAT I MEAN,
THERE IS NO BOOK GOING
THROUGH I SAID THAT MAKE
THERE'S YOUR SNOWSTORM WERE
THE ONLY SCHOOL THEY EVER NOT
HAVE A NON-CONFERENCE. I MEAN,
SO THERE'S A LOT OF FIRSTS
THAT OUR PROGRAMS GONE
THROUGH AND AT THE SAME TIME
COULDN'T BE MORE PROUD OF
WHAT THE RE AT. AND WHAT THE
TEAMS ARE.
ACCOMPLISHED THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS. SO THIS YEAR HAS BEEN
A YEAR LIKE NO OTHER AND WHEN
IT'S ALL SAID AND DONE AND
TELL YOU AGAIN EVERY COACH
CAN BE REALLY THANKFUL THAT
THE PLAYERS SACRIFICE WHAT
THEY DID TO MAKE THIS YOUR
POSSIBLE FOR ALL COLLEGE
BASKETBALL. WHAT'S YOUR FIRST
BASKETBALL MEMORY COACH. WHAT
IS THAT? MY DAD TAKING ME
RECRUITING WHEN HE WAS AN
ASSISTANT AT LSU AND I THINK
IT WAS PROBABLY TWO IN THE
MORNING. WE GOT PULLED OVER
FOR SPEEDING AND I REMEMBER
WAS SO COOL.
LOOKING AT THE FLASHING
LIGHTS AND MY DAD TOLD ME
THAT'S REALLY NOT THE THE
EXCITEMENT HE WAS WORKING FOR.
BUT ANYWAY, HOW IS ONE OF MY
FIRST BASKETBALL MEMORIES IS
GOING RECRUITING AND THEN
SEEING THE FLASHING LIGHTS
RECRUITING AND THEN SEEING
THE FLASHING LIGHTS AND BEING
ABLE TO SEE A POLICE OFFICER
TO YOUNG AGE LIKE THAT THAN
AN OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW WHEN
YOUR DAD STARTED COACHING AT
VALPARAISO AND I IMAGINE
THAT'S HOW YOU STARTED
GETTING INTO THE CONCEPT OF
COACHING AND PLAYING AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
ABSOLUTELY.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE MARCH
MADNESS COME ALONG ONE OF THE
MOST MEMORABLE SHOTS IS YOUR
BROTHER IN 1998. YES, GREAT
MEMORY ABOUT BALL OVER OLE
MISS AND 2.5 SECONDS LEFT
AND BRYCE HITS THE THREE AND
HAS A GREAT PASTOR. JAMIE
JENKINS WITH A GREAT CATCH
AND FEEDING HIM ONE OF THE
MOST MEMORABLE SHOTS AND
EVERY TIME I SEE IT, I STILL
SMILE. SO THAT'S AT THAT
THAT'S A GREAT THING IN LOVE
THIS TIME OF YEAR FOR COLLEGE
BASKETBALL FANS. IT DOESN'T
GET ANY BETTER THAN THIS. I
TELL YOU THAT.
THE TOUGHEST THING IS LIKE AS
YOU KNOW IN THE NBA PLAYING
BEST OUT OF SEVEN SERIES.
USUALLY THE BEST TEAM WINS,
BUT IN MARCH MADNESS WITH THE
PARITY IN COLLEGE BASKETBALL
140 MINUTE GAME ANYTHING CAN
HAPPEN SO YOU GOT TO BE ON
POINT AND THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE
SO MANY UPSETS AND EXCITING
TIMES. NO. NO, I DIDN'T KNOW
YOU'VE GOT EXCITING TIMES
RIGHT HERE IN FRONT OF YOU,
BUT I DO LOVE HITTING THE
WAYBACK MACHINE A LITTLE BIT
HERE. I MEAN, WHAT IS IT LIKE
BEING THE ASSISTANT IN A
HUDDLE WITH YOUR DAD? I
GUESS CALLING UP A PLAY FOR
TO WIN A FIRST ROUND GAME AS
AN UPSET IN THE 13 SEED
AGAINST OLE MISS. WHAT THE
HECK WAS THAT LIKE FOR YOU?
CAN TELL YOU IT WAS IS THE
ONLY TIME WHERE THE WHOLE
TEAM JUMPED ON THE PILE NOW
THE COACHES WERE SMART AND
WE WENT ON THE VERY TOP.
YEARS IN THE NBA, BUT THAT
WAS A SPECIAL GROUP. HE CAME
IN WITH AND THEY'D BEEN TO
THE NCAA TOURNAMENT SEVERAL
TIMES AND KNOCKED ON THE DOOR,
BUT HADN'T BROKE THROUGH AND
THEN TO FINALLY BREAK THROUGH
AND GET THAT WIN AND THEN I
GET I GET A LITTLE LONGER
COACHING MY BROTHER AND AND
THAT GREAT CLASS 98. IN FACT
ONE OF OUR ASSISTANTS ON HER
BAYLOR STAFFS JARED NOON IS
THE GUARD ON THAT TEAM AS
WELL AND HE'S DONE A GREAT
JOB GREAT JOB HERE WITH US
AND WHENEVER THAT HIGH LIGHT
HE MAKES SURE HE POINTS OUT
THAT THAT WAS THAT WAS A TEAM.
HE WAS ON I LOVE THAT.
THAT'S SO GREAT. NOW IT
WASN'T A MOMENT IN THE HUDDLE
LIKE HOOSIERS WHERE YOUR DAD
WAS USING YOUR BROTHER AS
A DECOY AND YOUR BROTHER AND
EVERYONE LOOKS AT YOUR DAD
LIKE WHAT ARE WE DOING HERE?
OKAY, I NEED YOU AND YOUR
BROTHER AND YOUR BROTHER SAYS
I CAN MAKE THE SHOT THAT THAT
WASN'T LIKE THE MOVIE RIGHT?
WELL, ACTUALLY IT WAS ONE OF
THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE HE WAS
CALLED ON THE COURT BECAUSE
WE WERE OUT OF TIME OUT. SO
IT WAS PROBABLY MY DAD HAD
YOU KNOW DAD ALWAYS KNOWS
BEST BECAUSE ME AND MY
BROTHERS ARE LIKE, WHY DO WE
PRACTICE THIS PLACE SO MUCH
WE NEVER USE IT. YEAH,
REALLY? JUST NO KIDDING.
SO DO YOUR KIDS NOW SAY TO
YOU HOW COME WE'RE CONSTANTLY
PRACTICING THIS PLAN. YOU'RE
LIKE SHOW ME ONE OF THE
GREATEST MOMENTS OF THE
HISTORY OF MARCH MADNESS AS
IT RIGHT AS AN EXAMPLE.
THAT IS SO COOL.
OKAY, SOSO, I GUESS WHAT IS
HOW DO YOU APPROACH IT? I
MEAN YOU YOU'VE GOT SUCH A
GREAT SHOT HERE. YOU'VE GOT A
GREAT TEAM HERE. YOU GOT A
TEAM WITH A BUNCH OF A BUNCH
OF CAN DO WANT TO THINKING
THEY CAN DO IT. SO HOW DO YOU
AS A COACH NEGOTIATE THIS
NAVIGATE THIS KNOWING THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT SITTING HERE
RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOU ON
MARCH 1ST. I THINK EVERY
COACH IS PRETTY SIMILAR IN
THE STANDPOINT. AND THAT IS
YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T LOOK AT
ONE PLAY AT A TIME AND
EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
SEASON THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DO AND CAN'T GET WRAPPED UP
WITH A MOMENT BECOMES TOO BIG.
SO WITH US, WE'RE REALLY
BLESSED. WE GOT A REAL MATURE
GROUP. WE HAVE A GROUP THAT
BASICALLY FOR TWO STRAIGHT
YEARS HAS BEEN RANKED IN THE
TOP FIVE AND IS
DEALT WITH EXPECTATIONS
DEALT WITH PRESSURE AND AT
CONTINUE TO PUT THE TEAM O
FIRST.
AND PLAY FOR EACH OTHER AND
BECAUSE OF THAT WE'VE BEEN
GETS YOU NO GUARANTEES, BUT T
DEFENSIVELY WE'VE BEEN ONE
OF THE TOP TEAMS IN THE
COUNTRY THE LAST TWO YEARS
OFFENSIVE, LY THE LAST I
LOOKED WE'RE FOURTH ON CAN
PALM PRIOR TO THE FOG, BUT
I CAN TELL YOU THAT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, YOU'RE NOT
ALWAYS GOING TO MAKE SHOTS.
SO YOU BETTER BE GOOD
DEFENSIVELY AND YOU BETTER BE
GOOD ON THE GLASS AND WE'RE
NORMALLY GOOD ON THAT
THE OTHER DAY.
KANSAS WE WORK AND GIVE
KANSAS A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
THAT. BUT THE TEAM THAT WE'VE
HAD FOR TWO YEARS IS GOOD IN
THOSE TWO AREAS. NOW I ASK
THIS LAST QUESTION OF YOU
WITH THE RISK OF SOUNDING
STUPID AND DUMB BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE WHO OBSERVE
THINK THAT A LOSS LIKE THE
ONE YOU JUST SUFFERED IS
HELPFUL THAT PRESSURE IS
REMOVED THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
AN UNDEFEATED SORT OF
PRESSURE TO KEEP IT GOING
THAT YOU DO SOMETIMES LEARN
FROM ADVERSITY AND
AND AND A LOSS. WOULD YOU
AGREE WITH THAT ASSESSMENT
COACH II CAN TELL YOU HIDE
INSIDE TELLS YOU THAT
EVERYONE THAT'S WON A
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP SINCE
INDIANA HAS HAD A LOSS BUT I
WOULD SAY THAT THAT'S THAT'S
A THAT'S A THAT MIGHT NOT BE
A BAD THING GETTING A LOSS AT
THE SAME TIME. THERE'S NO
COACH THAT FEELS GOOD WITH
THE LOSS NOR DO THEY WANT A
LOSS AND IF YOU HAVE A TEAM
THAT LIKES LOSING OR IS OKAY
WITH IT. YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT
VERY GOOD. SO NOW WE'RE ALL
MISERABLE RIGHT NOW.
AT THE SAME TIME WE'VE BEEN
BLESSED. IT'S OUR FIRST LOSS
SINCE LAST MARCH, SO
IF YOU CAN GO A YEAR WITHOUT
A LOSS. I THINK YOU'RE DOING
YOU'RE DOING PRETTY WELL. AND
HOW ABOUT THE KIDS THAT HAD
YOU KNOW THAT OBVIOUSLY THERE
HAVE WERE ON A TEAM LIKE LAST
YEAR AND THEN MARCH MADNESS
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC RIPPED
OUT FROM UNDER THEM. THEY
MUST BE SO FIRED UP RIGHT NOW.
THEY MUST BE THEY MUST BE
OUT OF THEIR MINDS THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
LAST YEAR NOW. THEY'RE ABOUT
SO THAT'S BEEN A BLESSING
OF GUYS IN AND I FEEL FOR OUR
SENIORS THAT FREDDIE
GILLESPIE DEVANTE BANDEAU OLD
BEEN THAT DIDN'T GET A CHANCE
TO PLAY IN MARCH, BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE RETURN A LOT OF
GUYS AND A LOT OF GUYS CAME
BACK TO COLLEGE BECAUSE THEY
WANTED TO PLAY IN MARCH AND
HAVE A CHANCE TO BE A PART OF
THE NCAA TOURNAMENT IS AS WE
ALL KNOW, IT'S A GROWING UP.
IT'S IT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU
DREAM OF IT'S SOMETHING
YOU REMEMBER THE REST.
- EVEN WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE
FANS ALL YEAR AND ALL THAT
THE KIDS GET TO EXPERIENCE.
IT STILL ARE GOING TO AT THE
END OF THE DAY, YOU KNOW THAT
THEY PLAYED IN PART OF THE
NCAA TOURNAMENT. WHAT A GREAT
MEMORY FOR THEM AND HOPEFULLY
IT'S ONE THAT WE COULD SEE
MICHIGAN AND US IN THE FINAL
FOUR. I'M GOOD WITH THAT YOU
GOOD WITH THAT. I WILL SIGN
FOR THAT SIR. I WILL SIGN FOR
THAT SIR. AND THE USUAL THING
THAT I HOPE OF MY GUESTS THE
RICH EISEN SHOW BUMP THAT
I'LL BE A BIT CONFLICTED ON.
THAT DAY, BUT I THINK YOU LET
YOU DO UNDERSTAND THAT RIGHT?
I DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND IT.
SO AS LONG AS WE DON'T PLAY
MICHIGAN JUST CHEER FOR THE
BEARS COACH SCOTT DREW. THANK
YOU FOR THE CALL REALLY
APPRECIATED. THIS WAS FUN. I
HOPE I HOPE YOU HAVE AN
OUTSTANDING MARCH IT GOES AS
WELL AS YOU HOPE APPRECIATE
YOU. THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
YOU BET THAT'S SCOTT DREW
HEAD COACH OF BAYLOR
BASKETBALL RIG